bacon let's see time now is 642 let's go
back to one of the other stories much
talked about at the moment London's
Metropolitan Police are considering
whether a joke made by committee and Joe
brand amounts to an incitement of
violence after she suggested people who
throw milkshakes politicians should use
battery acid instead the comments which
she made during a BBC Radio 4 comedy
show have since been removed from a
catch-up version of the program there's
a lot of debate about whether it
shouldn't they should have been
broadcast in the first place let's
discuss this now with comedian
Constantine kissing who joins us now
from our London newsroom good morning to
you and what do you make of this row
about this joke well I can see why
people are angry about it I think one of
the first things that needs to be said
here is there's a tremendous double
standard going on as someone who's
neither right nor left wing you can see
that if this had been a right-wing
comedian talking about a left-wing
politician say Diane Abbott their career
would be over by now they would be
ostracized they would never be on
television again so I can see why people
are angry having said that the way you
fix that double standard isn't by
treating everybody equally badly Jo
Brand is a comedian she was performing
as part of a comedy talk show called
heresy the point of which is that people
take extreme positions for the purposes
of humor right so you can expect that
something controversial will be said and
if you start to live in a society where
people get prosecuted or investigated
for jokes which is already happening
then you really know that a society that
society is not really free anymore and I
will just reflect because Nigel Farage
has commented he's given an interview to
the Sun newspaper and said it's and it's
kind of reflecting what you said when
you compared the joke that the potential
could have been made about Diane Abbott
it's just because it was me there are
some mostly on the Left who believe in
the European project to whom I am the
devil demon figure so our politicians
fair game and if they are fair game how
far can you go as a comedian this is the
thing is I don't think Jo Brand would
argue that this is one of the best jokes
it's probably cross the line but the
point for us as comedians is we don't
always know what's cross the line or
what's funny or what's not funny until
we've said it and I'm a bit disappointed
with Nigel Farage on this one because
he's usually someone who stands up for
free
and I think this is an issue of where
people need to ignore the party
political side of this and just say look
if we have a society in which comedians
start to get investigated by the police
for jokes that they tell we're not
really living in a free society but I
think an interesting point here as well
as in terms of the BBC itself it seems
to me that the BBC has been very heavily
focused on the diversity agenda recently
which is a good thing but one of the
things that doesn't seem to be reflected
in the diversity is diversity of opinion
there's clearly nobody in that
production room at this show who
actually said look this might annoy half
the country and I think that's telling
well the Prime Minister trees may her
spokesman has said that the BBC should
explain why the joke was and I quote
appropriate content to broadcast news
she's waded into that the Metropolitan
Police has confirmed it's received an
and I quote an allegation of incitement
to violence that was reported to the
Metropolitan Police on the 13th of June
are you surprised it's gone that far I'm
not surprised actually because this is
something that I've been talking about
for a long time we have a creeping
authoritarianism in this country
actually my debut show a dead remember
friends of this year's about that it's
called all well that ends well because
you might remember your viewers might
remember about six months ago I turned
out of safe space behavioral contract
from a university which said that they
had a zero-tolerance policy on racism
sexism classism ageism ableism
homophobia biphobia transferrable
xenophobia Islamophobia anti religion
anti atheism and demanded that all jokes
must be respectful and kind right so
this is happening in society more
broadly and we're starting to see I
think over three thousand people were
arrested in this country for things they
said online on Twitter etc so you're
seeing people arrested and prosecuted
and planned guilty frankly and being
fined for things that they say for jokes
that they try to make so I'm not
surprised because a lot of us have been
warning that this was coming what do you
make so the son reports on the newspaper
is also reporting that Joe Brown was in
front of an audience in Henley and and
said looking back it probably was
somewhat across an ill-judged joke
something that you've alluded to as well
constantan and that might upset people
of course I'd never do anything like
that it was purely offence
I'm sorry I'm a human I made mistakes is
this the future for comedians you know
make a joke only living but if you go
too far be prepared to say sorry well I
hope not and I'm glad that yeah I think
Joe has apologized but I also think
she's taking a pretty good stand on this
in terms of you know not really
apologizing fully and I don't think she
should apologize for I think that the
line that we have to hold here is to say
that comedians have the right to joke
and to make mistakes and making mistakes
as part of is part of the process so I
think we have to this is a point I think
it's a crucial moment actually in in in
this country for us to make a decision
do we want to live a society in a
society where you have free speech or do
you want to live in a society that has
licensed speech where what you're
allowed to say is determined by the
police essentially Constanza Nissen
thank you very much for talking to us on
breakfast this morning